yes there is neutral yet for the
significant AIDS and the last Game of
Thrones season the fan community gets a
little more nervous every day so far you
have to be content with the release
teasers and scenes from the HBO annual
preview since Game of Thrones is not
only a series by the worldwide phenomena
the excitement of many fans is to be
taken quite seriously
some even wonder if there will be a
trailer at all since the producers could
just lean back and release the season
just like that
after all the six episodes of season 8
will be full of decisive revelations
however from the official side there are
reassuring news there will be a trailer
even though nothing is known yet about
the time and for topic the producers
still have some time left for the
release until the start date on April
4th 2019 just remember season 7 when the
trailer was published only two months
before release we think there won't be a
trailer until the end of February but
you can definitely look forward to the
long-awaited release of the last season
Game of Thrones on April 14 last July it
was reported that the shooting on Star
Trek 4 will be due this January however
shortly after it was already on the
brink again due to fair contract
negotiations with Chris Pine and Chris
Hemsworth and now also the plant
director SJ Clarkson works on the Game
of Thrones prequel now it's reported
that the movie is officially unhoped and
it's not certain at all if the movie
will ever be shot as a conclusion fans
of Star Trek will have to content
themselves with the second season of
Netflix Sirius Star Trek discovery which
was released this week the mission
impossible franchise will get two
sequels at once and as we know for sure
also with director Christopher McCrory
and actor Tom Cruise the release of
Mission Impossible 7 is scheduled for
summer 2021 while Mission Impossible 8
we'll be shown in cinemas exactly one
year later in order to achieve this
ambitious goal both films will be shot
simultaneously a quite risky step if you
only imagine that Tom Cruise got injured
during one of the many stunts he mostly
has done by himself in Mission
Impossible fall out we have already seen
the significant delays that even a small
accident can cause according to Variety
there are probably enough time reserves
for such cases as McCrory is already
near completion of the script work and
therefore a shooting star this year
isn't unlikely understandably there
aren't any details known about the plot
yet but it's considered that Christopher
McQuarrie will again rely on wed
eastwood as Hollywood's number one in
stunt and action shooting we'll keep our
ears open for you and hope for news on
Mission Impossible 7 & 8 soon after the
rather questionable Ghostbusters reboot
from 2016 with exclusively female
leading actors fans have waited long for
a genuine sequel for the - Eddie's cult
films with director even reitman
fortunately Sony Pictures not only
confirmed a new Ghostbusters movie but
also has a big surprise behind the
camera however even reitman won't return
for the third part of ghostbusters
instead his oscar-nominated son Jason
known to many as the director of the
tragic comedy up in the air will take
over his part jason reitman who already
had a look behind the scenes of the
first Ghostbusters movie at the age of 6
and thus calls himself the first
Ghostbusters fan doesn't want to produce
another reboot but the next chapter to
the original franchise he also asks that
the story will be set in the present and
not in the 80s
of course fans of the original
Ghostbusters are now wondering if the
remaining original actors will marry
dead Aykroyd and Ernie Hudson will also
be part of
new film understandably jason reitman
still leaves us in the dark as it's very
early and he has a lot of surprises and
new characters included in the new
script the usually well-informed sauce
Hollywood Reporter also thinks it knows
that the four main characters will be
teenagers and that moving to a small
town will play a big role just as in
Stephen King's it shooting will start
this summer and the preliminary release
in summer 2020 is not too far away
either in conclusion it will be
interesting to see if and how the
original actors will be involved in the
plot and when we can expect a trailer
since a teaser was released only a few
days ago
[Music]